recording. All right, so this is video three, but they're great. It's a large genetic
series trading. We're starting to talk about the detox pathways. So this is really important
for cancer patients because of cancer patients are detoxifying. So remember you are what you go to
detoxify, right? And if toxins are sitting in your cells, then they get interrupted pathways.
And in your cells, how you how your body works as far as so there's different
there's different pathways that are for apoptosis. And I made some videos on this.
I think they're called apoptosis 101-201-301 that talk about these different pathways.
So they're super important. So this is the outside of the cell. This is the cell that right here.
This is the inside of the cell. And boy, it's all these different words that are very complicated,
right? But this is where we talk about what takes place inside the cell is like New York City.
There's just all this commotion of this stuff going on. So these capsaic pathways are super
important for turtied apoptosis. So apoptosis is a normal program cell that the recycling of
cell material that's happens normally. It's supposed to happen that certain times cell does not
live forever except certain times that sounds like brain cells and heart cells, but most cells have
a time of life that they're living and that they reproduce a new cell. The mother cell
goes through apoptosis and dies and it's basically recycled. And it's stimulated through different
receptors, put the cell bed, right? Like this is a death cell death receptor stimulation right here.
This is a receptor. And this is the problem with some bad estrogens. So bad estrogens, there's 33
different types of estrogens that can be blown in the body. And these, the quote unquote bad estrogens
like the 16 hydroxy estrogens that such can attach to these cell death receptors and block them.
So they don't attach to it and stimulate a process of recycling and cell death that apoptosis here.
They attach to them and block those receptors. So that's the main thing that's that bad estrogens
why they're bad is they can be causes of cancer or we should really say causes of a lack of
lack of apoptosis. So they block apoptosis so that that cell has a greater chance of bad things
happening to the inside and it's starting to replication cycle. And that's what's difficult to
then kill that cell. So that's what takes place inside the cell. This is just one little pathway,
right? So think of if a toxin gets in here, couldn't wreak havoc. In this one deep pathway,
and there's thousands and if not hundreds of thousands of these different pathways inside each cell.
So a toxin or a biotoxin, you know, elevator organ, so getting inside the cell can damage that
pathway and lead to bad things like cancer. So one of the biggest arguments why is we have this
increase in cancer rate? Why isn't, you know, just in the last few years literally go through the road?
Well, there's a lot of answers so that but you can't argue with the above. A poisons that we're
exposed to that are getting inside the cell is unprecedented. You never before in history. Okay,
you could argue that back in the 1700s, there was everybody just birdie coal and there was just
soot of the air at large cities and it was just disgustingly, but it was solely, it was how many
toxins were in that coal, right? So several, right? And that's not good for the lungs. So there was
probably a lot of COPD and lung infections and a lot of people died of pneumonia and all this kind of
stuff, but never before is the amount of chemicals that were exposed to. Even back in those days,
there was very, very few different types of dyes or clothing that most of them were all plant-based.
I don't think of what you're wearing or what you're exposed to. The chemicals in the
carpeting, the chemicals in the paint, we're just, we are smothered chemicals. Okay, so these pathways
are super important to look at because these are real big pausers of cancer. So you already know
this because you just explained this to be dysmortied, the different pathways that are tied to
glutathione. So you got the pathway that recycles glutathione, the genes that make the
enzymes that do that. This is the trans-alpheration pathway that feeds the baking of glutathione
and then you got there are two pathways that feeds it here, it's not on this chart that holds glutathione
along with the keyboard, so it's released or done, right? And then the SOD pathway here
that gets rid of free radicals and along with canales. So you got these pathways here
and then what we don't have charts for is the cytokine key for 50 pathways and one pathways and one
in AT pathways. So that's mainly what we're looking for as we go down these pathways.
So if you see a lot of defects, you're really following what's on here as far as what you're
going to recommend for that patient. So it is important to familiarize yourself over time with what's
in these products. So utilize the software to do that. A big piece of helping the entire detox system
is this product. So we're up into there's a lot of research that's come out on this in the last
couple years. Turmeric extract in this product is not the best form of turmeric because it's simply
turmeric extract. The best form of turmeric is the C4 per cumin away. That's it. We have it in two
products in the sun spectrum and in the curcuclear. It does have ginseng, pelvic reddit, which is good,
some of these other things are good too but so they just help push that pathway.
So always click on this even when you're talking to a patient so you can try to talk through it
a little bit and just help yourself understand this even more so. To keep one assist we have a
click because I think this person has to keep one defects. This also has the sulfur faded it.
So would we want to give a nerve to and keep one together possibly if that was their main problem
but not typically but this person has some defects in the recycling piece here.
And then down here I think their worst problem was SOT was really bad. Candelace that's pretty bad
and the nerve to and keep one they have defects of all three of their keep one genes
and that's that's really odd so you can see how
where they're ready to keep one is pretty bad. So that's why I had this person checked both the
pulse. So this would be a case where you might want to support both those pathways. So this person
actually has a cancer patient. Cytacrone P450 pathway this isn't so bad.
Of them you remember this is not this this this this gene is not in version five of 23 and B
it's in version three and four and this is the one that's your detox in sense of
that from other people's. Yeah so if they have a one you have to ward them
that they should be careful take you any insides if they have a two you really harshly warded
because statistically there's over 15,000 people a year the United States have died
of Tylenol and insan toxicity. Just a cute liver failure. And that's only the ones that are listed
as the cause. So you could imagine how many people die of liver failure every year.
More than how many people maybe probably maybe 10 times that amount really realistically.
So if all they did is run this gene and say oh you got a two here you can't be taking this stuff
they could save thousands of lives every year. So this gene is really important that this is
one of the genes just this one alone makes me want to not do version five because that is version five
they just pulled it because they don't care about the medical pressure they're just carried about
because that's necessarily for ancestry. Is that all right? It is in auto-cakes and you look at see
how bad this person is with their pun blood and it says it here and I really wish Bob would change
this. It says pesticide. This is where how you detox pesticides. Really if you look at pun blood
I actually did a video on pun blood. It's much more important with that it's very important with
cancer patients. So it detoxifies large chemicals in this pathway including vaccines. So people
that have issues with vaccines. So if I was like I'm trying to decide whether I should get the flu
shot or not I would look at this pathway right here. I would look at my nerve and my key pathways too
but this one would be the most important along with my MTHFR genes here. This one is 677 mainly.
This person doesn't have anything but if they had even if they had deep defects in this pathway
I'd say that you should not get vaccinated. So if you do your little baby had defects like this
and you put the vaccines in the schedule that they have used today that kid could probably have
learned disabilities. So yeah it's amazing how a $200 test could give you a lot of data that you
could save somebody's life. That pathway detoxified large chemicals also and so understand these first
of all let's take a step back. Understand these pathways. This pathway is how you detoxify
enzymes? Well wait a second. Why did God give us this pathway when he created mankind before
enzymes were ever developed right? Okay well they just discovered that enzymes are detox of this pathway.
There are other things that are detox of that pathway too. So that's just you know the pathways that
you have that are supposed to get rid of junk in our body that are now having to be used by so you
think think about this way too. Think think of you know biology we had these pathways forever right?
Well a thousand years ago what was what was carried on those pathways? Not very much okay that's how
we're supposed to land right. And no it's almost like you have a ton of transportation system that was
created or let's let's say let's say it in Atlanta I don't know if you ever driven through Atlanta
or Chicago or LA. How busy it is? What if they still had the roads that were built in 1840?
Yeah. Did you understand? With the traffic today. That's kind of how your genes are you could describe it
that way. It's like your genes you are created to detox your grade grade grade grade grade grade grade
hooting toxic and now your detox scene similar to so that was you. I go to a good rush hour
that it's like you're you're already done pathways that were built in in 1840 but you talk
everything's a dirt-tooling road that was made to handle horse travel that you
got the same load of traffic that you have today. How would that work? So it's
amazing that we're all alive. It's really what you think about it. It's amazing
we're not home dead. Let's keep making more temples. That's keep making more
chemicals because we can make money. So supporting these pathways is
important and we could use these products to support the pathway and people that
argue, oh, you're treating the steps you should not treat the steps. That's
really wrong to treat the steps you can't do that. You're treating that is
your absolutely particular statement. You're not treating the steps. We're looking at
the person's defects that they have. While we look at the person's history and
their symptom pattern and what their current diagnosis is. Here you're not a
person with cancer that has these defects and you start putting together some
pieces of the cause here. It's like, okay, well this is no under this person has
cancer. Look at their detox pathways and then you're going to all we're going to do
is support these pathways so it works better, right? And you're not going to just
use these products that are just listed in here. There's other things that you
could use. Certainly so if we go to you, let's say I may, let's say let's say I
have pound one defect. So I like that product so I used that a lot because it
tends to work real well for people. But when I click this, that's often just a
reminder for me to do something else when I get to the supplement. So if I was
the one writing this software, I would have in here as a clickbox a whole bunch of
other choices. So it's easier for me, but I understand he's going to make it so
it's not so complicated or someone who's just getting started in this and they
don't know really anything about supplements and they don't know how to do
that but it just makes it a little bit easier to pull back. But I might have
checked or two here where I'm really just going to give them the broccoli late or
the broccoli product, the broccoli clear that we have, that was just going to be very
high in the sulfate versus given this product. Do you know what I'm saying? So I'll
check these boxes to cycle through this just to remind me or knowing that person's
history and stuff. I may want to use just milk, this or detox and tea or
something like that. You know, based on how they'll either history. Plus you
got to know how the product is delivered at no either patient. So some people it's
much easier for them to take a pill. Some people it's much easier for them to take a liquid.
Okay, so you got to get a balance now all those ways. Does that make sense? So questions
about the detox pathways from such here. So when I explain this, I say see these three genes
right here, these three key point genes, these might be the most important.
It all the genes from here on up. So we could say, oh wow, they're, they're
glutathione production is really good. And this person could be taking glutathione products.
And well, they don't know all this glutathione, but if they have these key point gene defects,
they don't release it. So what good is that? And SOD is really important, right? Because you have
to get rid of superoxide items. So this product right here could prevent a lot of problems
with people. So would it be good to look at somebody's genes when they're 14 years old, right?
And they don't have problems. And if you looked at this person's genes when they're 14 years old,
if it was available, then you put them on some SOD and some broccolidate and some canelase
uh supported that there are two people on with silver or fade, right? And that would help support
the contact way. Although if that's all you put them on, you could possibly prevent a lot of
disease in that person, right? But they might not have cancer today if you would have done that
10 years ago, right? Yeah. So the folate pathway is this pathway here. So it's how you take in
green leafy vegetables. And remember these are all genes that make enzymes. So the enzymes that are
made by these genes break down those green leafy vegetables, also to make better tetrahedral folate
to go into the affinity path. So this is the entrance to the affinity path right here.
So these purple things are things that block these genes from working correctly. So one could
one could argue, well, it's really the environment, not really the gene. Well, the truth is it's everything.
It is the gene. If I have a double allele defect on my MTRR gene, that's going to affect
the utilization of a methyl tetrahedral folate into the thyroid and the utilization of methyl tetrahedral
folate into the ideal and hydroxyl comolubines to make methyl comolubine product too. So that's
going to affect B12 production. That's going to affect the dieting direction. Plus to the bathroom
and she'll be right back. And then she just wanted to, if you could let her know what time I
could put that side. Did you just let her get on the video?
That's just frustrating. There's no note on the toe.
Yeah. Hi, brother. She will see if you can find it. Yeah, I don't know if she can find it.
So you see the things that block it. So I'm talking about these before. So look at those things today.
Okay, so back to the folate pathway. With cancer patients,
I hesitated to mention this already to give methyl products to many methyl products and push this
too hard. I think even with a blood cancer patient, you're much better off really pushing this with
having to eat more acrylic vegetables, right? So this is the danger of folic acid. So you've got to
that section. How bad synthetic folic acid is. It literally blocks this. There's beliefs that
synthetic folic acid actually causes the MTHFR defects. So when you see this MTHFR defect here,
like these defects here, this person's going to do there, there's beliefs that it's actually just
synthetic folic acid that is the biggest thing that's caused that defect. Okay? So again, you're
probably better off having supplementing this person, which is having to eat more acrylic vegetables.
Now, especially if you see this 1298 defect here, this one here, you have to suspect some
emotional issues too. So remember, we talked about emotional issues in the bio genes, right?
But this pathway, this whole biopterate pathway, is going to be pushed by the 1298 gene.
It's up pushing the biopterate pathway. So the biopterate pathway right here,
1298 MTHFR is going to push that. So those defects there are going to play with this.
And you add a top of that, a bunch of mild defects. They've got single little cup defects.
They produce a little bit more glutamate than normal. And they got the DAOAG defect.
This person probably has some eager issues, short fuse, you know, type of things going on.
If you gave them a bunch of methyl groups, it would be worse.
So I think who is it that tells the story? I think it's Ben Lynch, tells the story about he talked to a
doctor, whose daughter, all he did is run a test. He read a different lab down to 23. He read a lab that
just measured, you'll get this a lot. You'll hear this from people that just measured like 30 genes.
And one of them was the peptide gypargy. So the doctor said, and then she had a true kind of
the letter was, but she had some defects on this. So the doctor said, you need to go on
methyl tetrahedral folate. So put her on methyl tetrahedral folate because the daughter was
had a depression and you just kind of got to come out of her room and all this got to stop. So we put her
on methyl tetrahedral folate, the person put her on like 5 grams higher dose. There's multiple
companies that make pretty high dose. So you look at some of our products. So you look at this
MTHFR, MTR product right here. So it says three capsules contain 600 micrograms, okay? So
if you talk about five grams, that's really really high dose, right? So that, if he talks about
the doctor college, or him and say, my daughter, what happened to my daughter, they had to call
the police and they had to put her in a straight jacket because she grabbed it, I threatened to kill
people in the house. She let it freak us away. He took her off. What are the things you can do with
that? That would be what people have described as there. They are at a state of hypermethylation.
They're overbethylated. There's different terms that people have used for that. How you could
call that down and pull out methyl groups in a person if you overdose the person is give them
diacid. So you give them diacid and that's okay. And that flushes out the methyl groups.
And then he said if he gave her diacid and she curled up in a quarter and looked at what
was in a quarter. So it's about about it. Okay, we'll head to here. Thank you.